guaranteed income tends to break up
families it makes it easier to be a
single autonomous adult if it guaranteed
income you know to stay together
families need to depend on one another
in order to be strong well Bernie
Sanders might be out of the race his
socialist policies and ideas remain a
Gallup poll shows that 43% of Americans
believe some form of socialism would be
a good thing compared to only 25% in
1942 today more Americans associate
socialism with social equality and
government control back in 1964 in the
middle of the Cold War President Lyndon
Baines Johnson LBJ created what's called
the Great Society and put into place
many of the social welfare programs we
have today including Medicare Medicaid
educational reform sparking the
beginning of the wave of social
democracy we see today with the economy
currently in the biggest collapse since
the Great Depression we should now be
looking back and what worked what didn't
and how we rebuild the economy a Manish
Flay's is renowned historian who has
spent her career studying the effects of
the Great Depression over the years
she's written for everyone Wall Street
Journal Bloomberg Forbes National Review
she serves as chair of the board of the
Calvin Coolidge presidential foundation
and she's the author of four New York
Times bestsellers her latest Great
Society a new history is more relevant
than ever she offers new insights into
why the social programs of the 1960s did
more harm than good and what challenges
await us if we continue down this path
today we'll talk about how the best
parts of the Great Society are the ones
that cost the least amounts of money how
the nation's economic success starts
with what we do in our own families and
what to expect when the government plays
God
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special this week
we're joined by a MIDI slave and just a
reminder we'll be doing some bonus
questions with our guests the only way
to get access to that part of the
conversation is to become a subscriber
so head on over to daily wired I come
become a subscriber you'll have access
to all of the full conversations with
every single one of our awesome guess
how many thanks so much for stopping by
thank you for having me one of the
things I've been talking about a lot on
my show and in my writings is that there
are sort of two versions of American
history that have now come to be taught
one is the more traditional version of
American history that America was
founded on eternally good and true
principles in the Declaration of
Independence embodied in the
Constitution of the United States not
perfected at the time obviously didn't
live up to those principles the Civil
War helps us draw a lot closer to those
principles and civil rights movement
Ross has even closer but that America
was founded on good principles and we've
been moving toward fulfillment of those
principles and then there's an
alternative history that's been put
forth that suggests that America is
eternally rotten terrible founded on
racism sexism bigotry homophobia that
the only good points in American history
are essentially large government
intrusions into the life of Americans
the 1930s in the nineteen sixties
specifically areas that you've written a
lot about so which of these two versions
of history in your view is more accurate
and why do you think that there is this
bifurcation the former is more accurate
it's a better country than most other
countries we should be proud of it and
sustain it but the that part of it is
the reason poor economics is used to
assail the private sector the companies
in the 1930s or the 1960s so the
standard history of the Great Depression
for example is that capitalism failed
the evidence suggests it didn't the the
actual evidence suggests that the
government as one economist of the
periods had played God and when the
government played God the economy
suffered by intervening too much but you
know sort of elephant in the room
chasing you into the corner with his big
trunk that's that's what the government
was in the 1930s it's very clear it's
also there's also plenty of economic
edit evidence so I find it particularly
puzzling that the left-leaning narrative
would be so compelling to people for
example what's the kindest thing just
sticking to the 1930s you can ever do
for anyone that thing is to give him a
job and in the
1930s the government created jobs here
and there through big programs but the
net was unemployment was over 10% a
level we can't even conceive of the
whole time loving people tried to help
people they loved and hurt them
so I want to talk about sort of your
your history books because you've
written really three that then I'm aware
of that have made a big impact one on
Calvin Coolidge and then you wrote one
on the Great Depression in FDR's policy
and then you have your brand new book
great society new history we'll go
through each of those in turn exciting
kits important for people to know about
these periods which are so formative and
how we think about history today in
economics but first I want to take a
moment to give a shout out to all of our
advertising partners who help make this
show possible we are super grateful for
their business and we certainly
appreciate it if our listeners can do
what they can to keep our sponsors going
the advertisements keep our show going
and you our listeners patronizing our
advertisers that also keeps the show
going we're all trying to get through
this together you me the advertisers
we're all gonna get through it together
and we'll see on the other side right
now your online more than ever you know
who else is online a lot hackers and
they're looking for your data I'm sure
many of you are working from home these
days without your IT department to
protect you from online threats it's
important you take action on your own to
secure your devices the devices you use
for work that's why I recommend using
Express a VPN for the best online
protection possible I've been talking
about expressvpn on my show for so long
you already understand why encrypting
your network data is so important but
some of you still have not acted why
well you might be thinking security
threats don't affect you personally but
not using expressvpn that's kind of like
leaving your front door unlocked every
time you go out and just like there's
been a jailbreak by mayor's across the
country also that a lot of hackers who
are now finding a lot of Liberty online
nothing might happen for years when a
break-in does happen it is devastating
one of the easiest ways to secure your
internet data is with Express VPN you
click one button on your computer or
smartphone you are now protected my only
question is why haven't you done it
visit my special link right now
inexpressive VPN comm slash Ben get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep my data safe
that's expressvpn comm slash Ben alright
so let's talk about your your first book
on Calvin Coolidge so you write a book
on Calvin Coolidge which whose
apparently the most boring president of
all time according to most people he's
rated always very low when you have
historians rate American presidents they
always put him near the bottom always
FDR is very high LBJ is very high
Coolidge they place very low your
history of Coolidge suggests that we
should be viewing Coolidge precisely the
opposite the reason this is important
obviously is because Coolidge is
president right before the Great
Depression and is very hands-off in
terms of his economic policies so what
do people not understand about Coolidge
well first of all ranking presidents
shouldn't be a zero-sum game and people
like to rank in baseball if they have a
high person they want a low person
because they wanted to be zero-sum right
that's not useful for presidents really
though although it's fun so if you want
FDR to be high which is where the
premise starts I want Roosevelt a loving
intervener to be high Coolidge was
temperamentally and in terms of policy
opposite to FDR so ergo Coolidge has to
be low and they put him very very low
people tend to like a strong man or a
great man depending on the phrase you
know the word great is always associated
with the presidency Coolidge said it's
it's not a good idea for the president
to be a great man in fact he said it was
a comfort to the president and a safety
for the people when the president aware
is aware he's just a man oh that's very
very different and that model goes
straight back to George Washington who
chose not to stay in office forever and
wrote his famous farewell address about
how the country needs to move on and
that that's very important to us our
government is important it's more
important than any individual we don't
want presidents to turn into dictators
or have dictatorial power I thought this
was fantastic the economic record of
Coolidge is similarly trashed
because if you believe in intervention
FDR then how can you like
non-intervention but people go and get
all tangled up because it's very hard to
attack college for example sometimes
you'll hear a tax on Coolidge that his
interest rates were too low and that
caused a bubble
what were his interest rates his
interest rates were hundreds of basis
points higher than our interest rates so
if he was loose what are we now he and
his Fed right he was catastrophic a lose
well we're apocalyptically loose then
and we're going to have a hundred
percent inflation and hyperinflation by
the
same argument that usually progresses
make against Coolidge which is sort of
the Great Gatsby argument if you know
from popular culture well it was all why
in a champagne bubble and the market
went too high and he goosed the market
too high he didn't actually Coolidge
didn't comment much on the market he was
trained by Andrew Mellon a very
interesting Treasury secretary not to
panic the market because uncertainty is
bad in econ so you make yourself very
still so you don't scare the elephant or
you you know and that's just good sense
so we didn't ever say and the stock
market is way too high and it's
dangerous because he felt that itself
was dangerous but he also believed the
the white house should stay away from
the stock market remember in the 20s
there was no Securities and Exchange
Commission there was no serious national
regulation really of the stock market it
was all de New York had laws right it's
different that's where the stock
exchange was or Massachusetts had lost
that Ponzi scheme was prosecuted in
Massachusetts not by the federal
government so much these are all
relative but anyway Coolidge saw it well
if the market Falls it will happen as
has had happened so many times in my
lifetime it will fall and people were
learned that maybe stocks sometimes go
too high and they shouldn't have all
their money in stocks that was the net
of it that's what it happened before and
every time before well
the recovery had come fairly fast there
was a Great Depression in the early 20s
that Jim Grant has written a remarkable
book about called the Forgotten
depression it was really deep
unemployment in some places was 15
percent we would notice that but it was
so short that we forgot it and that was
what was the economic policy the
government responds to this period well
depression seems to be coming or we have
inflation let's raise interest rates by
hundreds of basis points oh that's
counterintuitive too and let's cut
government which is opposite to what we
would do now now we would spend a lot in
government to fight off our recession
there that the reaction was what
technically is called procyclical that
is we made it worse sort of but that
also made it very short that was the
standard response insofar as there was a
response to downturns then when we get
to the Great Depression where Coolidge
wasn't managed
rather Herbert Hoover and FDR were they
took the opposite position they said
let's wait in let's org reorganize the
economy let's great business a lot of
things that had never happened before
let's insist that the labor price be
high because that will stimulate demand
very new idea at the time and all these
factors contributed to along with
monetary to get to to launching the
Great Depression and then sustaining it
so there's not a lot of you know I must
say one more thing in the Great Gatsby
image it was all fake right it was just
shiny dresses and champagne bubbles and
there was no real growth but the reality
of the 20s was incredibly solid growth
they've even at Harvard HBS now at
Harvard Business will write this up
they're studying the patent rates of the
1920s because they were so astronomical
a lot of ideas including pre television
that we consider 30s or 40s ideas were
thought up in the happy 20s um that's
all suppressed all that memory because
of the desire for a narrative that
blames Coolidge blames market and
elevates government and what does that
say about the study of history because
when you when you look at historians
very often what they do is they they
tend to take presidents toward whom they
are favorable in terms of politics and
then contrast them with other presidents
very often dishonestly so instead of
contrasting Coolidge with say Wilson
which would be more of a contemporaneous
comparison given the fact that Wilson
was by the time he was out of office
deeply unpopular leading to Harding his
election given the fact that Wilson had
presided over an unpopular war that his
economy had started to fall into
complete tailspin by 1919 1920 that the
reaction to that is the election of
Republicans who then lead basically a
decade of astronomical growth instead of
contrasting Coolidge with Wilson instead
what they do is they contrast Coolidge
was not around during the Depression
didn't handle the depression with FDR or
they make up a false history about
Herbert Hoover said they can falsely
contrast Hoover with FDR when in reality
Hoover was actually implementing
policies that were almost precisely like
what FBAR did except FTIR just deepened
it a little bit yeah Hoover is a bit
like MIT Romney or his father George
Romney is a can-do man who liked to take
charge and he meant well and he was a
community man but he was wrong I don't
understand
the whole thing I do understand that
since you and I have grown up the
history books have gotten worse so it's
very hard to find the correct history
well and I do understand the desire I
mean it's very very important for young
people to rebell against them on online
and check it out for themselves they
don't have to believe you or me they can
go look at the record if the 20s saw GDP
grow fast
if one remarkable thing Coolidge did for
example was he actually cut the budget
and nowadays when we talk about cutting
the budget we mean reducing the rate of
growth of the budget that's part of our
lying right to ourselves
he actually literally cut it nominal and
real he actually it was a lower data
point when he left six after being in
office 67 months that's very important
for right now because sooner or later
we're gonna need a president who
couldn't cut the government and join
Congress and that here we have one in
Coolidge and I think just precisely
because he was so good he is
intentionally obscured I don't mean to
be one should be paranoid but one should
be unrelenting in the pursuit of the
reality of the event the real reality of
the 1930s is the Great Depression was
great because of that God playing I
remember when I was writing forgotten
man which is the 30s book I came across
an economist he wasn't a weird Austrian
unheard of economist he was the chief
economist of Chase Bank and yes he was
actually kind of Austrian in modern
language but at that time that was
mainstream by the way the kind of
economics you and I are now speaking was
the economics of the United States up
till about 1948 so and Benjamin Anderson
of the Chase Bank wrote in the Chase
newsletter government shouldn't play God
that causes economic uncertainty mark
market freezes when government is
playing God with lots of random
decisions so true so predictable is so
understandable we never learned this and
once it's interesting to ban I will say
once I had discovered Benjamin Anderson
the chief economist of J's bank saying
all the things I thought might be true I
felt better with my book but most
Americans had not heard of
Anderson then one time I talked to a
free-market adviser of President Putin
this is in the day when President Putin
had those advisors it was under Al
Arianna visits name he's now at Cato but
anyway at that time his email was
advisor at Kremlin gov or something cool
like that advisor as oh wow and he said
Emma D Benjamin Anderson Anderson
Anderson Anderson he's the greatest they
knew all about Benjamin Anderson in the
free market Club of Moscow or Leningrad
but they didn't know here that's how
much our education was obscured that in
a communist country a high economist
could know more about the breadth of our
history and our economic analysis than
we get at our institutions here let's
move on to it's had forgotten man
because obviously we're talking about
that period it is a stunning book
particularly because it takes the these
who will Sounion concede that you're
gonna have the best men at the top of
government the bureaucrats at the top of
government who know more than the rest
of the market combined and can implement
policies that will somehow even out the
economy for everyone else and you really
see the ugly results of that in FDR and
his and his cabinet his brain trust
because in my goodness when you talk at
the beginning of the book as I recall
about the about the manipulation of gold
rates
I mean it's astonishing stuff to realize
that American national policy was being
set based on FDR's lucky numbers well
that's right well this is all about
arbitrariness versus rule of law so if
you have a bunch of rules even if
they're imperfect they might be better
to follow than have one random leader
however charismatic because we want
markets we don't want just tribal
kingdom it's sort of a choice like that
we want to be able to operate with
relative confidence in markets the
market doesn't have to be perfect it
just has to be not too bad as Adam Smith
said you need easy money easy taxes
that's what I meant not not too bad not
too bad situation and then the economy
will grow like crazy you don't need a
perfect situation so that's what we
needed and that's what they took away
Roosevelt had no understanding of that
he was an arbitrary guy he liked to be
arbitrary he was very charming it goes
for the territory and what happened
specifically with goal what you're
- is they couldn't figure out about
where gold fit into the Great Depression
we did have a contraction a deflationary
contraction okay that was a problem so
we went off the gold standard but and he
wanted to reflate so we started let's
see to buy gold you know he he was just
just like you and me he was talking it
through his head he said well all I will
set the price of gold and buy it here
but he didn't understand that gold no
longer mattered because he had gone off
the gold standard it didn't have the
magic it would have had buying and
selling gold before he went off the gold
standard so he was very confused and
very random and what's wonderful in that
story is that Henry Morgenthau was his
Treasury secretary and was kind of the
fool on the stage as in Shakespeare who
is a fool but also speaks truth - in
spite of himself Henry Morgan doubt the
future Treasury secretary went home and
wrote in his diary Roosevelt is taking
the gold price because he has certain
lucky numbers and he's using those lucky
numbers to pick the gold price let it go
up 21 cents why mr. president because 7
times 3 is 21 and 7 is a lucky number or
3 is Morgan that went home and wrote in
his diary if anyone knew how the United
States set the gold price they would be
frightened
yeah and markets were frightened and
that contributed to the duration of the
Great Depression and that happened over
and over again in many areas the
government intruded scared people like a
dictator people froze we had what we
call capital strike or business strike
one of the most famous stories in the
book for their two stories in the book
that are worth for calling one was out
here in the West we had a government
farm called cat at Casa Grande Arizona
which is kind of outside Tucson now
outside actually outside Phoenix sorry
somewhere in between the two and Casa
Grande was a real Animal Farm the
government provided everything the
people were supposed to work
collectively and be happy except it was
humans they had to share the tractor and
in exchange they got really nice homes
these were people who would have been in
you know John
Steinbach otherwise who didn't have
enough food who didn't have combs who
didn't have shoes necessarily very hard
times and what they discovered was that
no matter how much they gave the people
including a really nice Community House
a really nice chicken coop with a rare
government chicken in it that that you
know that would be more I don't know
productive more eggs that people didn't
like it they said I want my own tractor
I don't want to collectively farm for a
wage which is what Casa Grande was I
want to own my farm and get profits and
the people eventually went away that's
because a big government program tends
to go against human nature that's what
the casa grande animal farm farm
experiment showed the other story in the
book that people often referred to was a
small chicken butcher in Brooklyn and
his case went to the Supreme Court
that's ala Schechter poultry V NRA and
the or an IRA and the chicken people had
a little kosher wholesale butcher outfit
right the slaughterhouse and the
government came with the New Deal rules
and told them what to do in the New Deal
rules didn't make sense to the little
chicken people and kind of went against
their custom as well so for example
under the New Deal rule for reasons that
are just absurd people weren't allowed
to pick their chicken any longer they
had to take the chicken that came out of
the coop when the butcher pulled it out
well they want to pick their chicken
this is in the era before antibiotics
they they want to know they have a
healthy chicken that's all many many
ethnicities like fresh poultry and
they're right they want to see the happy
healthy fowl before it's slaughtered and
they know their dinner will be great so
this went to court the schecter brothers
were charged with many many fines than
they could go to jail
felony basically and they it went to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
found for the chicken butchers is that
government can't reach this far this is
too much it abuses delegation it abuses
the commerce clause and so on and you
know what the stock market went up after
the schecter case
was resolved siding with the little
chicken butchers the Schechter's and
that I think was because the market saw
that there was a limit to what even new
dealers could do in the US economy so so
these are very interesting stories about
arrogance of government essentially
arrogance of government hurts
jobs arrogance of government mean leads
to outrageous mistakes the mistakes of
the New Deal arrogance of government can
be avoided as well there was a study
recently that came out from UCLA a
couple of professors there found that
that FDR's policies had lengthened the
Great Depression by at least eight years
that the the deep government
intervention ISM had scared away capital
that the attempts to prop up wage rates
by lowering production in particular
areas had prevented people from getting
food that that the tyranny from above of
forcing businesses to adhere to laws
with literally they would they would
tell people that they had to put symbols
in their windows if they were adhering
to government policy that none of this
had had a particularly salient ory
effect on the American economy and yet
the history that I was taught when I was
in social studies in in middle school
was that FDR had saved the country
during the Great Depression that if had
not been for FDR and his interventionism
if it had not been for the New Deal and
and all of various programs associated
with it that America would have
collapsed into complete dust and or
tyranny complete dust and or eternity
well one thing you just look at the
stock market today people think I'd ever
rising Dow is their birthright that was
gonna go up because we're great right
well the Dow did not come back until the
50s from its pre depression level and
that was not because pre depression was
that much too high it was because people
didn't believe in capitalism anymore
government and depressed them and the
Dow of the 60s just to get later was
really key one counted on it getting
past a thousand it didn't get past a
thousand until Ronald Reagan imagine if
we had to wait decade plus more to get
to 30,000 well our children and friends
would be mightily disappoint pointed
including all
people of pensions and in the stock
market included teachers at tiaa-cref
right so the evidence is definitely
there you're so right I think one reason
with Roosevelt is he was on the right
side of World War 2 war Trump's econ
it's a sad little story for economists
and for the economy but war Trump's econ
he led us in rescuing Europe so people
are simple-minded they don't want to
hurt Roosevelt for his little domestic
errors say my mother who's now gone
unfortunately what she loved Roosevelt
because of what he did in the war so she
was willing to forgive that other stuff
it was too complicated that's not useful
for us if we're operating in the real
economy or for setting policy now to add
a sentiment sentimental affection for a
war leader ignore economic evidence that
hurt our grandparents or great
grandparents or parents the second thing
is teachers like government especially
when they're in unions I like government
too I admire it but it's so often wrong
third is you know it was set in the 60s
there was a Italian writer Gramsci the
philosopher and also in Germany that
when the left didn't win in the great
sixties upheaval they would do copy Mao
and do a long march but in America the
long march would be a long march through
the institution's they would get tenure
they would become judges and that long
march did happen so now if you go to
school and you find teachers almost all
of them are going to be more progressive
they hang together they're progressive
and they reinforce each other and they
write the books um I also would say I
don't hate it but I think it's wrong for
the College Board to have such a
monopoly on all the economic testing
culture that then a new testing culture
needs to be created there's a test for
classical education now I'm very
interested in because if to get a 5 on
the AP to get in college you need to
believe that Franklin Roosevelt saved
America in the Great Depression you're
going to believe that and we move closer
to Easter up then then is comfortable
for us in fact there's a diversity of
evidence in all these areas Ben and the
econ is pretty unmistakable freer is
slightly better for the United States
inflation is caused by government when
it's too big we haven't had inflation
yet this time that doesn't mean we never
well our freeways will be completely
impaired - the interest rate go up well
one day the interest rate will go up the
other factor I think that has an impact
is the revisionism that takes place
between World War two in the 60s which
is this idea that FDR has put the
American economy on new footing and then
after World War two things explode forth
because of the new footing of the
American economy when in reality it's
pretty fairly evident that the reason
that the United States economy leaps
forward is because we're literally the
only country on earth that is a major
industrial power that has not been
completely wrecked all the way to the
ground it turns out that gives you a
hell of an advantage in terms of
competitive right right that's very
important there's a joke about the 50s
they say Democrats go back to the 1950s
in their minds because they want to work
they're very well paid decade for also
unskilled workers Republicans go back to
the 50s because they want to live there
because this were conservative it's very
interesting but the absolute truth is we
could raise wages as much as we liked in
the 50s because Asia was not a threat
Europe was what do we consider you're a
potential customer for our product that
is what the Marshall Plan was for not so
they could start their own factories and
in the explanation often it was so
Europe would have enough money to buy
our stuff that's how it was sold sort of
as a Commerce Department venture - in
the United States so that's one thing
another thing is like think about when
you're in college and your junior year
your college wins the pennant and how
much you love the coach and the team and
if you're on the team that stays with
you forever right
there are there studies that suggest
that if your college one junior year you
are going to be a better donor than
anyone else your college all things
being able it forever because the high
of it can never be replaced well the war
World War 2 was it an even greater high
those people those soldiers those vets
returning home associated Roosevelt with
the high of their life
we saved Europe how can they stop and
quibble about economic policy again but
its associated with the major high for
the US Norman Podhoretz the great
intellectual said regarding the 60s when
he heard about curing
ready that sure we could do that we've
won in Europe I mean compared to winning
in Europe isn't curing poverty in the
United States a small thing and petard
said well we regarded Turing poverty in
the United States as a kind of mopping
up action not too hard
relative to the other things we do if
communism can go away in Europe then we
can have socialism here same thing you
know people look at what happens
overseas and they say well I mean it
sometimes it's very perverse they say
well that couldn't that big thing can
happen here we can do this here they
draw the wrong lessons sometimes let's
talk about Great Society because now
we've reached the 60s and the the fact
is that the economies you talk about in
the book is booming by the early 60s
during the JFK administration we have
very high rates of GDP growth and there
is this sort of belief that it settles
over America that finally we've reached
the end point that if we just engage in
massive government redistribution of
schemes and major government involvement
that we can cure poverty once and for
all and after all we are in the midst of
changing so many of our mores in other
areas some for good and some for ill I
mean I'd argue for ill in the sexual
revolution but for great good obviously
in the civil rights movement you talk in
great society about the this notion
being pushed by members of government by
union leaders that we are right on the
verge of finally you basically yeah
exactly right the Great Society is
important why we spent tens of trillions
what would happen if we had those tens
of trillions we could erase the debt
imagine if we could get up tomorrow and
say there's no more American debt we
massively misspent when we spent on the
Great Society the good parts of the
Great Society in my view were the ones
that cost so much money such as the
Civil Rights Act which came at and the
Voting Rights Act which came after it
which basically established or affirmed
the most basic rights of people one in
ten black men in the south voted that's
wrong state of Mississippi it has to be
fixed Voting Rights Act people couldn't
sit down at a lunch counter that needs
to be fixed it was fixed so those things
were not expensive
they were emotionally expensive and
politically charged but they were not
expensive because they were rights of
freedom was sometimes known as negative
rights which is
to say rights about your individual not
that to which you're entitled which is
positive right so those were great but
then Johnson who was the president kind
of switched over and he said I'm gonna
build a Great Society in the classroom
the countryside the city and first he
said that was all about opportunity less
expensive veni said it was about what
one is owed very expensive and and you
can mark the shift from freedom to
entitlement in a speech he gave at
Howard University where he said
basically it's not enough to free people
and give them the opportunities other
people have you that's like putting a
lame person at the start line of a race
and then of course he's not gonna win
and you go haha you lost that's cruel we
need to help people all along until
they're really ready to compete with
others that idea went just absolutely
exploded into massive spending in all
areas it led to affirmative action that
we have still with us today but many
other projects too that we're kind of
that did the opposite of enfranchisement
they disenfranchise people by chaining
them forever to welfare welfare like
programs I mentioned food stamps and
sometimes people attack that there's
nothing wrong with the poor family
sometimes receiving food stamps there's
something sick about for the family
mostly of the family expecting it will
always be on food stamps and its
children will and its grandchildren will
and that's sort of what we've created
the Great Society basically just
increased in increased commitments for
spending made some very interesting
legal shifts one legal shift was at the
beginning of the decade and spending on
benefits was more like charity from the
federal government the law change
through the Yale Law Professor Charles
Reich through the Supreme Court in a
case called Goldberg V Kelly we're
essentially benefits became property
where we got the word entitlement you're
entitled to it as a patent owner is
entitled to the rents from his patent
the property from his patent that's a
weird idea why should people be entitled
to payments that
someone else because when you spend for
one person to get entitlement property a
benefit you're taking away someone
else's property his money he must pay
the taxes for this project so so our
property rights hurt or helped yeah
Charles Boyk is very interesting because
he also wrote the greening of America a
sort of crazy left-wing manifesto mixed
up youth manifesto but the I think his
property rights analysis that welfare
his property was incredibly damaging to
our society I mean there's so much in
the book that I didn't know even as
somebody who's studied the period and
that that's absolutely shocking that the
federal government openly sponsoring
people to agitate against the government
in order to stump for benefits as was
one thing that I found absolutely
shocking yes a mayor your tea of Los
Angeles and Mayor Daley of Chicago are
both in the book and I want to let you
know because of my own progressive
education and perhaps yours
I never thought mayor Richard J Daley
the boss was such a hero I I grew up
around independent Democrats who really
hated him because he ran a machine and
it wasn't nice he said you know my
parents grew up in Chicago sort of like
Mussolini I mean you know the snow plows
came when it snowed but he wasn't nice
and they weren't particularly part of it
either because he had Daley was an Irish
machine but I grew to like Daley in this
book and even your T of LA because the
mayor's had ideas for poverty we this is
a Tocqueville society the United States
of America where community comes up with
ideas and understands very well what's
needed in their community mayor's do
even when their communities people of a
different race that can happen right so
Mayor Daley had all his poverty ideas in
a box and he supported the Democrats
Kennedy Johnson in 64 and so when
Johnson gets up in announce this big
poverty program Mayor Daley says great
Lyndon puts all his ideas in the box
I mean ties it with a bow big box and
sends them into Washington here's what
you're gonna give me money for programs
I've started with my employees that is
not what the Great Society did instead
Johnson's people led by Sargent Shriver
also of Chicago was they created their
own
federal poverty office in Chicago they
tapped their own friends and those
friends were picked by the poverty
office in our war on poverty in Chicago
we're really left-wing they even gave
money to the Blackstone Rangers through
the Woodlawn organization so they kind
of supported a vigilante Protection the
way the US government has occasionally
done in Medellin in Colombia in drug
places you give guerrillas money so they
won't shoot so many people and will
become something tamer like a police
force but it's a creepy thing to do
that's essentially what we did and Daley
could not believe it the federal
government was giving money to people
who wanted him out of office and who
were gonna cause riots in his city and
sometimes they still could and he called
up the White House and he said just
President Johnson now he's giving em a
and E why to support some people so I
began in reading the humiliation and
frustration of these mayors and reading
of that to understand how undermined our
towns were to an extent that we still
suffer from today the mayors just became
mendicants who needed money from
Washington in Washington always set the
terms that was a surprise to me
it's amazing how none of the ideas from
the Great Society have ever truly died
like even going away I mean what we're
watching right now in the 2020
presidential race is the reflection of a
great many of those idea of you Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren and even
more extreme forms I mean literally
while we are filming this Bernie Sanders
was tweeting out that we ought to have
national rent control and he tweeted
that out today and the first thing that
I flashed to was the the Pruitt I got I
go government buildings I in in your
book because I actually tweeted out a
picture for those for those missed it
because because the fact is that the the
policies that were being pushed by the
Johnson administration were these
policies a right to housing and
therefore we're gonna literally knock
down entire suburbs and just put up
government housing it was it such a
terrible idea that is he talked about in
the book they had to basically knock
down all the government buildings
because it was such a terrible idea and
yet that is coming back and it's coming
back stronger than it than it was maybe
in the 60s well you know one thing about
the old New Republic writers
the progressives of that period is they
were quite honest and one of them I'm
thinking of is Nicholas von Hoffman and
he has the story about leading a rent
strike that is exactly what is under
discussion now make the bad landlord
who's a Rat Fink profits here be nice
and bring down the rent or do something
else for us to repair this or that and
Nicholas von Hoffman this writer was
then a young activist maybe working for
Saul Alinsky and he went and there was a
meeting with the evil landlord and the
landlord came and he had a piece of
paper and he said to his lawyer who was
with him tell them it's like science and
fuller says the landlord is willing to
give you angry tenants the property for
$1 because he can't afford to maintain
it
even at the rents you think are too high
or whatever he can hit the business does
not make sense to him there's no way
even if he wanted to help you he could
he's losing money so would you like the
property for $1 and Nick from Hoffman
went home and had a stomachache because
his whole premise of left-wing activism
over rent control or bad landlords who
don't replace lightbulbs or get he was
blown away
the poor little landlord gave up he said
you can have the property here I'm
scared you're bothering me you make me
feel like bad man most landlords aren't
bad men or good men they're somewhere in
between like all humans and just the
mere economics of it didn't work out in
the case of pruitt-igoe which was this
massive housing project perhaps the
biggest in the United States tower after
tower the premise was economic growth it
didn't happen they never filled the
public housing that is the the st. Louie
housing authority never got the revenue
it thought it would based on the economy
of scale of these towers and massive
growth just had too little revenue to
pay for fixing up these towers the
tenants were very unhappy there were
rules for the tenants that basically
drove out the father's because if you
weren't dadless you didn't get a good
apartment the sons went wild and broke
all the windows and
made terror cells of the elevators and
the this dreamy utopian public project
with rent control became a dystopian oh
so sad in fact one of the interesting
things about pruitt-igoe they did
eventually blow it up there were it was
a shame of light of st. Louis not a
pride was that there was a Catholic
priest named father Shockley who worked
there a long time I want to work in
public housing I want to help poor
people I'm a progressive and he
eventually concluded that the best thing
he could do for the people at Breuer
Daigo was to move them out into houses
of their own and help them buy them so
there's little project buying little
houses and the people really like to
have their own house and they actually
knew how to paint their house and the
dad got to stay and it was a miniature
but valuable success story so to see
people replicating this today there's
also a story about guaranteed income
which is in the news guaranteed income
tends to break up families the the Great
Society people who again we're sometimes
more honest than we are now commissioned
some studies and some of those studies
were actually funded by the Great
Society to see what happens when you
give families guaranteed income in one
thing it does obviously is it it makes
it easier to be a single autonomous
adult if it guaranteed income you know
to stay together dad or mom it if
families need to depend on one another
in order to be strong sometimes the dad
needs to be the breadwinner
sometimes the mom needs to be the bread
but anyway they need to be together
and an ending come tends to divide
people I have money now I don't need you
okay so let's talk for a second about
Union strength so one of the the big
things that the Democrats are pushing
the West has been pushing recently is
the idea that that America's economy has
not been growing equally because of the
decline of American unions that if
unions were stronger than they could be
pushing in the private sector for more
wage gain in the private sector the idea
is particularly that manufacturing and
industry that those industries have
fallen behind that the Union lack of
Union strength has led to all of this
you talk at length in Great Society
about the Union contribution to the
Great Society Union involvement with the
Great Society and you also talked about
the fact
Union States just basically stopped
growing and very often fell behind
economically so what happened with
America's unions were they good for
America's economy were they bad where do
they stand they made labor too expensive
and that didn't matter when we had no
competition when we began to have
competition the unions were indeed very
powerful they did indeed push up wages
and they made our automobiles
uncompetitive
just to give an example let's stick with
the United Auto Workers because I focus
a lot on Walter Reuther the UAW leader
the Detroit auto union leader he got so
involved in politics and pushing up
wages to help his workers that he failed
to notice something on the landscape
that was the freight ship bringing over
Toyotas the Toyotas docked the little
Corollas and ruled out they were
ridiculous they were small they ate our
lunch eventually it could contract the
story it you know telescope they ate our
lunch we didn't notice Oh Americans like
Toyotas oh by the way they're better
made why is that
they're better made in part because and
this was new to me really been I mean
when I studied it the some people have
studied in business school you know
Japanese assembly in line projects how a
Japanese assembly line might differ from
an American one we were in this dance
were curvy employer and it was pretty
rough on the American assembly line it
was not pretty you when a worker was
unhappy with the way something was going
he couldn't stop the assembly line it
was it was modern times and the unions
kind of like that because they like to
sustain the hostility between the worker
and the employer that led to angry
assembly lines and junky cars in Japan
which we think of as such a rigid
Society a worker could push a button and
the assembly line would stop if you had
an idea that might make the assembly
line work better and they listened to
one another more which week you know in
our stereotype don't think his Japanese
such a hierarchical culture and so on
the unions there were weak so their cars
were better than our cars and they made
more cars per hour their productivity
began to have strip us in the 60s
as they recovered from World War two all
of a sudden Japan had cheaper better
cars or Germany had cheaper better cars
so the idea that a union is great you
can have that illusion if you have no
competition if you want to go the Donald
Trump way and even farther and have
giant protectionism which the Democratic
Party has to consider as well then you
might for time be able to shut out
competition but not for long because
people really like those Toyotas yeah
we're seeing this now in negotiations
over the u.s. MCA where where the unions
really got into the process and now have
demanded that a certain number of men
hours going into the making of cars be
produced at a certain wage and that is
supposed to hold true in Mexico as well
as in the United States if it seems like
a great way of pushing up the cost of
vehicles past what Americans are gonna
be willing to buy in five or ten years
wait a minute or two Americans one is bi
and the one who's working and you know
the alternate is education all Americans
are capable of improving their education
or that of their kids it what if we
hadn't done the Great Society the
spending part what if we had spent that
all I'm making sure every kid knew
algebra and trig imagine what a culture
we would have one of my favorite
characters in the book is one of the
civil rights leaders his name was Robert
Paris Moses Robert Paris Moses he's not
the Robert Moses who built the houses in
New York and built the bridges and
tunnels
he was a Stuyvesant alum from the math
High School in New York who became a
math teacher and then decided is going
to be a civil rights activist went to
the south grew disillusioned with the
Johnson administration wanted to help
black young people and started
eventually something called the algebra
project which won a MacArthur grant a
genius grant to teach all poor young
people especially his community blacks
algebra I'm for that that's where the
energy should have gone and by focusing
on identity in groups whether it's labor
race we mislead our own country one of
the things that happens in the aftermath
of the Great Society programs we have
complete economic stagnant basically
from the late 60s all the way through
the very early 1980s and then
there is this sort of pushback not
against the spending programs but at
least against the taxation and the
regulation via via Ronald Reagan you
have Bill Clinton basically acquiescing
and the idea that the era of big
government is over and then in the
aftermath of 2007-2008 obviously that
all goes away
obviously the American mentality has
shifted we are back into government big
government big time if we ever left it
but the truth is that story which is
told so often by Republicans is not
fully true I mean the fact is that these
entitlement programs never really went
away that the Reagan administration
spent an enormous amount of money as did
the Bush administration so here's the
question are we ever gonna get past the
Great Society or are we doomed to
basically ride this train until it runs
directly off the rails and we'll be
forced into austerity because economics
is reality unfortunately I think we'll
be forced into austerity there's a nice
new some new books about austerity it's
not always that bad but of course it's
it's not great to have it will be hard
what it is is we're a casualty of our
own success nothing is new is the motto
of this book it's just forgotten nothing
is new and when you're doing so well you
just assume growth assume the economy it
for a long period we were able to tell
ourselves we could outgrow our problems
but the way the entitlements are now
rigged they grow with the economy and
that's technical these are formula for
example Social Security the richer we
are the better Social Security benefits
are going to be it's it's not that I'm
two years older than you you get the
same pension as I do from Social
Security adjusted for inflation that
would be fine you get more than that you
get something that rides with the
average real wage so my younger brother
actually gets a better pension than I
did forgetting about inflation I think
most people just think if we adjust for
inflation that's it that would be fine
but but because Social Security formula
have to do with the quality of life you
can never outgrow Social Security it's
hard to outgrow Medicare as well so this
idea the old idea let's outgrow it is a
little bit passe I you had the honor to
work with President Bush on economic
growth project and my main job was to
get up self-assign and say well I'm not
sure we cannot grow this we have to
reform at this time guys so
yeah that's the problem one of the
things about Ragan was he could never
bring himself to undo many programs but
we kind of have to forgive him because
he was in a rather serious war which was
the Cold War remember Star Wars was not
just a fun idea it was created out of
desperation this idea of a shield in
space to end the arms race and nowadays
when people talk then about military
spending if you look at a graph of
military spending it's way down from the
past one of the ways we mislead people
on television is to say as a share of
discretionary spending defense spending
is huge yes but discretionary spending
is a smaller and smaller part of the
budget so when they start to talk to you
about as the share of discretionary
discretionary they are misleading you
look at the whole budget because all the
entitlements are in mandatory and
they're bigger and bigger they've been
bigger for a long time now than defense
don't let anyone tell you it's all our
troubles are because of defense spending
ok so there's an argument that's been
kind of interesting on the right between
I'd say you know I'm on one side I'm
much more libertarian when it comes to
economics and they're there folks who
are sort of in the first things category
there's a magazine called first things
where they write very often about sort
of economics and and society and and
their argument goes something like this
in the 1960s the Democrats came along
and wrecked the family structure through
government intervention ISM and social
engineering and now those institutions
have basically been destroyed the
destruction of those institutions means
that there is no way for communities to
recover and thus we should use the means
of governments in order to pour money
back into communities that have been
broken thanks to government policy in
the first place there's a call for
government intervention ISM that is
designed toward helping dying towns
helping Rust Belt towns you see Tucker
Carlson talked about this on his show a
lot is that destined to work or is that
destined to fail in the same way that
all social engineering projects seem to
fail evidence suggests that will fail
the UM in the 1960s already they knew
that it was bad to separate families
Lyndon Johnson knew it and said it JFK
he knew it and said it so it's already
myth that they didn't know that and yet
they managed through there Gary
he didn't come for example to disturb
the family the family is so important in
the United States who can fix the family
only the family only the community
locally and this idea of Tocqueville
from above which is basically TOEFL he
understood the American community let's
help the American community from above
usually doesn't work so Tocqueville has
to come from the local the local town if
you and and what do you need to give a
community so that it can form itself and
help itself you need to give it space
and breathing room you need to take the
elephant out of the room I think that
electability is also part of this drive
it sounds nice every family gets paid X
another child credit another longer
paternity leave whatever that is sounds
nice government can't afford it and it
doesn't usually work it just sounds nice
so I'm sad to see this direction let's
just play my game say oh let's cut the
capital gains rate in the United States
to five percent benefit plutocrats or
let's triple the child credit which will
be better for the family absolutely
cutting the capital gains tax because
then every dad who at a business would
make more money every daddy traded
stocks would make more money every mom
we traded stocks would make more money
every mom where the business would make
more money
and guess what they'd be able to pay for
their families and their community let's
call the reduction in the value of the
charitable deduction because there are
many ways in which charitable deductions
as wonderful as they are are limited by
the tax code let's hope that and make it
even so a charitable deduction is really
valuable so that when you give charity
money won't be taxed on that money that
would be great
that kind of thing so you can make low
cap gains or not even enhance just
neutral charity that it returned to
neutrality more school choice not
through the federal government but
locally you begin to see all the things
you want sometimes you know communities
think it's easier to assign one person
that would be the president to fixing
the family it's not like that
to fix itself and it can but we have to
acknowledge that how do we fix the
teaching of history since the beginning
of the 20th century with sort of the
rise of folks like Charles beard and
then later in that line you know 50
years 60 years of mine the Howard Zinn's
of the world there's this rewriting of
American history that happens a pace in
which instead of looking back at history
and reading history through its own lens
there's an attempt to read history
through the modern ones so stuff that we
like right now we look back in history
we identify the seed of that and that
seed becomes good because it has
produced this thing that we like right
now and if we want to change effectuated
then we look at history through the
prism of what change we would like to
see effectuated and this is very openly
talked about in the 1920's 1930's by the
new historians and the and the the idea
of rewriting history with an eye on on
what sort of social change we'd like to
see what sort of perspective should
historians take when it comes to looking
at facts because obviously we all have
our own in prison when it comes to
looking at facts you look at the basic
evidence in our case we've been talking
about the Dow Jones Industrial Average
and employment particularly employment
of the poor in the later history well
the evidence is pretty strong you're
fixing history right here by offering a
different point of view or a different
set of data
I have great trust in people to make
their own evaluation I'm concerned about
the way history is taught in schools one
it's taught more left than it should be
but two it's not taught enough they want
the predominance of the Social Sciences
which presume that we can solve things
if means the eclipsing of history which
is as the historian said Chansey doesn't
always come out the way the theory would
suggest and there's a wonderful antara
bowl terrifying serendipity in that you
know oh my gosh if something ended up
the way it shouldn't it almost happened
for example relating to labor right now
we have right-to-work states and non
right-to-work states and non
right-to-work states you kind of have to
be in the Union and there's only one
Union and the employer kind of has to
accept that Union and the jobs leave
there that natural experiment is very
important thing for the United States
that's how we learned that unions could
be counterproductive what if we hadn't
been allowed to have so-called
right-to-work
well that almost happened it was on the
Democratic Party agenda to end the right
to work exemption which was part of
taft-hartley law it just happened that
Lyndon Johnson got a little tired after
the Tet Offensive and so on then he
didn't have time or energy after all the
civil rights legislation and Medicare
and Medicaid to put through an end to
right to work so this loophole stayed so
all these states grew and showed us that
perhaps you unionization is an
impediment to growth and employment
never would have happened had we just
made the whole country non-right-to-work
which is indeed what some of the
candidates are proposing now is there a
way to put the genie back in the bottle
here so the constitutional bargain has
been rewritten broken it's it's one of
the problems with governments is
obviously that you have discrete
beneficiaries and diffuse victims now if
with every government policy it's easy
to see the person who gets the check
it's very difficult to see the millions
of people from whom the check came is
there any way for Americans to to
re-establish that constitutional bargain
and move back toward a system of
negative rights versus positive right so
that's really what both the Forgotten
man and the Great Society are about is
this transition from the actual rights
of the American Revolution to these this
kind of second Bill of Rights that
includes all of these entitlements yes I
do think Reagan came up with this name
for California when he ran for governor
the first time in the sixties Ronald
Reagan and remember he wasn't so known
then I mean known in California known as
an actor but wasn't all going to be
automatic to the presidency the way we
think of it now he said we have a
creative society not a great society a
creative society and if you permit
creativity then you will see recognition
through doing a business comes
understanding and the importance of
markets and he really believed that and
it was true so I believe we live in a
super creative society now people are
doing things they never imagined they
could and change is happening in a
faster rate than it's ever happened
before so I do believe through alternate
paths of Education whether it's new
forms of video podcast streaming YouTube
a lot of things you're doing
or through contests if people are
managing to educate themselves one of
the things we do at the Coolidge
foundation where I am is provide the
education about Calvin Coolidge to high
schoolers through economic debates that
if they have to debate the economy they
see that Coolidge had some merit so they
can make up their own mind they argue
both sides but but I really do believe
in work arounds in education as
important for the future of America that
sounds tame education I really believe
in it well why do you think it is that
so many of these sort of economic elites
in our society have bought into the
nostrils of the Great Society because
you would think that those would be the
people who leave the fight against it
and indeed throughout your books you
talk about certain entrepreneurs who
were leading the fight against this sort
of government intervention ISM and
saying this is not the way I run my
business this is not the way a business
ought to be run and yet now increasingly
what we see is sort of our great
business leaders who are speaking out on
behalf of government intervention ISM
who are openly something in favor of
government intervention ISM is that just
because they're looking for a specific
benefit from government or is it because
they've been cowed into submission by a
politics that declares them malefactors
of great wealth if they refuse to if
they refuse to kowtow well there are two
questions one is economists economists
their problem is they're in a guild as
opposed to entrepreneurs at the
beginning right they're in a guild they
have to please one another they prefer
to be powerful to be into being accurate
sometimes right so the guild believes
you want the favor of the guild in this
book in Great Society had the story of
Arthur Burns a really great economist
who completely caved broke his own oaths
like you know and gave us inflation even
though he was a great scholar of
inflation out of vanity and political
politics because he wanted to be loved
by the president businesses it's a
different matter when they're publicly
traded they're almost part of government
already warning do not go public do your
business because then you are heavily
regulated you can't do it you want it
can't be a family business and you can't
you know all the the sets of rules of
for shareholders now are are so onerous
that CEOs are basically hired to pander
to
the business press in the world which
includes a whole lot of social justice
talk that probably isn't good for the
employees of the company or for the
shareholders so in just one second I'm
gonna ask you one final question but if
you want to hear a MIDI phrases answer
you have to be a daily wire subscriber
to subscribe head on over to daily wire
comm click subscribe and you can hear
the end of our conversation there a midi
slays the book is great society a new
history go check it out today thanks so
much for stopping by really thank you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike joiner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Katie Swinton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex's
and Garo editing is by Jim Nichol audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo the venture Pierrot shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]